why did you pick peter thiel as the
subject of your first book and something
that i'm assuming you spent three or
four years working on yeah um well so so
i'm really interested in
the story of kind of how
um silicon valley became what it is
right and and i mean like this you know
it went from you know being important
and culturally relevant you know in the
1990s but kind of like a sideshow still
even during the tech boom to being you
know i would argue
um the most important economic center in
the world um the most important cultural
center in the world and
um maybe it's not quite the most
important political center in the world
but it is but obviously it's becoming
more relevant politically um than it was
and and the story of how does how does
this kind of outsider industry um become
so important in our lives um and that's
you know that's anyone who's been
covering tech right like that's the
story we've all been writing and um you
know just when i was thinking about um
you know who's been involved in that
story i think peter plays a big role
right um as you say and i totally agree
there are other people you could you
could sort of tell the story of silicon
valley through somebody else
and there have been like these other
very important figures but but i think
peter's trajectory is pretty unique and
pretty interesting you know paypal um i
think even people who know about it even
people talk about the paypal mafia i
think they kind of underrate
um just how influential it was not not
in terms of i mean of course it's
influential in the ways that like you
know it's how people move money on ebay
and it's this big valuable um payments
platform but i mean in terms of creating
um kind of a playbook uh for like how
startups are built um and i think uh and
i think so i think peter is really
important there i think he's really
important in um facebook you know one of
the defining companies um you know maybe
the defining company of the last um 20
years um you know
peter and elon of course have have a
complicated relationship but um
but you know that relationship has been
really important to both them and i
think you know it's hard to imagine
spacex like i think spacex you know
maybe probably succeed would succeed if
peter hadn't invested in it but
certainly
but but he played a big role in in in
making sure
that at a very difficult time in kind of
the business trajectory of elon musk
when during the recession stuff you know
he was there um i think founders fund um
just played this a huge um not just in
terms of of finding important companies
but in terms of like articulating kind
of an intellectual case for
um startups and a very specific kind of
um you know startup building philosophy
i think
say the same thing about um zero to one
and so i think like all that
just by itself right would be enough to
justify a book because he's an important
figure but why did you pick him what is
it about him that made you interested
yeah yeah yeah so i and and so but then
there's then there's what happened in
2016. where um where where teal who is
as i said this important figure um does
something that i think people probably
who knew him weren't hugely surprised by
but the outside world was surprised
because you know how does a venture
capitalist somebody who's you know
obsessed with the future obsessed with
you know um bringing about change and a
very specific kind of change end up
endorsing you know um
uh basically a reactionary and how does
how does an immigrant you know
get behind somebody who's running a
candidacy that's basically a nativist
candidacy um how does how does a gay man
um get behind somebody who's from
political party that has has been super
hostile to to gays and lesbians and i
think there's like a really interesting
and um and complicated story you can
tell but like that that contradiction i
thought is really interesting right and
i like i'm somebody who is interested in
in kind of what
in those kinds of contradictions
and and that's what drew me to it
initially and as i dug deeper you know i
do think that you know for all the
reasons i articulate the beginning
peter's important but he also saw
something that was pretty pretty
important with trump even if you can
disagree with the with his you know
decision to support trump but he engaged
politically at a time when i don't think
as many people in tech were engaging
politically and he was kind of ahead
there too and i think even if you regard
the trump thing as a as a you know it
sounds like from your intro you do as as
a disaster or you know huge mistake or
something um
i think you have to also agree that it
was kind of brilliant in a way um as an
investment um and and so anyway i i
think the comments be brilliant as an
investment i mean it's basically made
him a pariah in the tech industry so why
would it be
no i i don't think it's i think it's
certainly
well when i say that his business is
investing in companies and uh nine out
of ten founders who would have taken his
money before supporting trump i think
wouldn't i mean people of course you
definitely hear that but but i mean
people are still taking his money i
think that well it's not just that i
hear it it's that i'm
one of the most active investors in the
world so i see it yeah you know no i i
look i i i respect the point of view i'm
just saying i think if you look at his
net worth if you look at um how his
companies have done you know in that
time um
he's still making a lot of big
investments um maybe they're not the
same investments that he would have made
you know i just think it's like a this
might be the one thing that and we'll
get to obviously um
this seems like an interesting jumping
off point because i think that's you're
a new york media guy right like uh
worked a fast company you're a career
journalist
yes how old are you
uh i'm 39 39 so you've been around you
actually remember the dot-com boom you
were graduating high school at the time
right now yeah man i was reading wired
and uh yeah you know i remember it so
it's it's just uh very interesting to
read your perspective of it as an
outsider or a journalist from new york
versus being here in it um because i did
think it's incr i was actually very
impressed with how accurate the stories
are having witnessed them firsthand
from you know the stanford stuff into
paypal i think all of that you nailed i
think this concept that he is extremely
powerful and influential
was the part i was like huh or that
people were scared of him um you
mentioned in the book that people feared
him uh
and i'm curious
where that came from because i think
over since
before trump is slightly before trump he
became less relevant in silicon valley
because he was less active in actually
investing directly in companies
uh and you know it kind of handed off
founders fun to brian singer man and the
crew over there luke obviously had left
to start his own fun so i think his kind
of power base he kind of gave up right
so
do you where did you get this um
perception that he's feared in silicon
valley i mean i heard it from
many many sources um and i think
um curious yeah
yeah i i mean i i can i can understand
that somebody like yourself um
yeah i don't think you have a lot to
fear from peter thiel um uh but i think
if you're a startup founder um
uh people there is a perception that you
know uh that that sort of breaking with
um you know that the the sort of paypal
mafia consensus um uh either on politics
or in some ways on tech you know makes
you difficult to fund um and i i
recognize like i i think they're people
and i talked to you know former uh teal
fellows who kind of explained to me uh
people both who disagree with peter's
politics and those who agree with them
and you know i i i heard how teal
fellows kind of have to navigate it
right because they recognize that some
invest some potential investors um don't
agree with peter and don't you know
would never you know invest in his
companies um but i do think there's
enough of a kind of conservative
community um even there you know even in
the belly of the beast um where i don't
think he's quite the pariah that you're
kind of painting him to be
zendesk is the go-to tool for customer
support and they also offer a suite of
tools designed to remove the
difficulties of cell's software you can
get access to zendesk suite of sales
tools plus their industry leading
support software free for six months as
part of zendesk for startups you'll also
get access to zendesk's community of
startup founders and partners and
dedicated onboarding guidance and
support here's a little testimonial from
one of my portfolio companies steezy
they sell software to learn how to dance
these uses zendesk explorer and their
ticket tagging system to track which
features their users are most excited
about then they relay that info to their
product team which is just brilliant for
steezy zendesk creates a positive
relationship with members and it
empowers them to contribute to steezy's
growth
so here's your call to action the old
cta in the business get six months of
zendesk for startups free at zendesk.com
that's right to qualify you must have
under 50 employees have raised a series
a or below and be a new zendesk customer
what a great deal you can get that six
months of zendesk for free at
zendesk.com start building an amazing
customer experience at zendesk.com twist